this meeting is being recorded let's
continue
and there's a man in your bushes i wish
there was a man in my bush
i mean all right what a start what a
start to this interview
erica it's been a minute yes you can
talk now
to some extent yeah more than i could
yes
uh well
you basically went straight from
reunion slash
deposition by andy cohen
into filming this season yes how much
did what unfolded at reunion change your
approach to the group moving forward
i think it got worse
look these last almost over a year and a
half have been really turbulent for me
and so i have just worked very hard to
continue to tell my story my truth and
um basically shout it from the rooftops
and felt like a lot of times i haven't
been heard or didn't want to be heard
and
i think that that's what you'll see this
season i hope for nothing other than i
came here with an open heart i honored
my commitment i stood up for myself and
that's all i can do
coming out of reunion did you trust any
of your cast mates more trust any of
them less well sure i mean you know the
thing about housewives is you really do
have individual relationships with each
woman so
of course you trust some more and others
less and that's based upon their
behavior on and off camera and you know
who they are to you in your life
both on and off camera the trailer hints
at some
explosive moments i think the the moment
that people really
reacted to was the i don't care about
anybody but me moment
right you want to be on the side of the
victims because you think that's cool
what i'm telling you it's cool i don't
even think about anybody else but me
what led you
to go to that place your frustration
again pure frustration i'd also like to
um i'd like for the audience to keep in
mind context in which it was said and
you can only advocate for yourself and
take the high road for so long and try
to be
you know humble and soft and then when
you're continuously pushed back and
called names then you
you go you know what
i'm not being heard and you get
frustrated with that and so that's why
you hear the frustration and the anger
in my voice and also too i do have to
focus on what's in front of me as well
you know i i do have a lot in front of
me and it needs my attention for sure
what's something you wish your castmates
understood about your situation the
complexity of this situation that it's
not going to be wrapped up in two
seconds that it's going to take a long
time um i don't think anyone on this
cast understands how many layers there
are to a law firm to a marriage to
partnerships to things like that that
you know perhaps there the people are
not looking in the right place they need
to look at those who actually work there
i am not a lawyer and that's where the
attention needs to be
would that same thinking apply to the
audience or is there more that the
audience needs to
kind of get on board with i feel like
the audience is the audience people are
going to pick sides and however they
feel about it you know some of the more
sophisticated audience members have
looked into it again like i said this is
a complex
situation and it requires you know
a little bit more patience than just
calling it out i don't like her so
therefore you know these bad things must
be true i'll never get away from widows
and orphans even though it's not true
i never had it it was never in my hands
it was never in my account there's a big
difference between civil liability and
criminal behavior and i think that
people don't understand that and
you know
you can see that reflected in the
comments
uh people not understanding what it is
a big criticism of you from the audience
and the women last year was not speaking
in support of the alleged victims sooner
you ultimately got there at reunion
do you wish you had said it sooner is
there any regret you have about how much
you shared and when you shared it last
year so um as we said earlier my hands
were really tied and i said all that i
could remember that there were many
cases being filed against me at that
time so less said is best said in those
situations i also think that people
misunderstand my concern and my
compassion for those who have been
wronged and they will be taken care of
of course i want to see that i also feel
that people need to
understand that i've walked right up to
the line as to what i can and cannot say
the women continue to question
everything you choose to share
this season the bankruptcy trustee says
erica girardi never touched the lion air
money
okay
other than erica saying that they've
been disproven
i've seen nothing not in the paper not
in the blogs nowhere if this is true why
isn't it in the press
what do you think it will take for them
to believe you
i don't know that they ever will i don't
know that it's in their best interest to
believe me because they need something
to hold on to in order to you know
that's that's on them i know the truth i
know what's coming i know what's
happening i can't um
live my life worried about what others
think when i know what's going on so
again
more sophisticated eyes more
sophisticated ears are willing to step
back and take a look at the total
picture and they're not willing to jump
on
sensationalized headlines it does seem
that you're taking inspiration from
yourself a little bit this season from
what we've seen in terms of giving zero
f's
would you say that's accurate this time
around or are f's being given well look
rice i do care but here here's what i
also wanted to have a good time i've
been under you know what feels like a
lot of pressure to me for a very long
time and i wanted to enjoy myself and
have a few drinks and have a few laughs
and of course
you know here comes the judgment so
you know
it's fine do you have any read on how
much more is ahead of you is there a
light at the end of this tunnel for you
um yes there is light at the end of the
tunnel and it gets brighter every day um
it's slow to come but that's okay i knew
this going in i knew this going in so
i am
you know i'm gonna soldier out i mean
that's the way it is they just push
through
i'm not giving up
you mentioned wanting to have a good
time relax have a few drinks it does
seem that
drinking becomes a question for the
group and maybe self-medicating is a
topic that's brought up
oh my god i'm lit pick your
antidepressants or you drink you can't
do both
how would you describe the erica we're
gonna see were you on a destructive path
at all or is it being kind of blown up
to more than it is i think it's being
blown up to more than it is but look i
definitely mixed medication with alcohol
and i've been very upfront and honest
about that
um i also wanted to have a good time and
um
you know sort of numb that feeling of
pressure and that that you know that
judgmental
heavy stuff that was coming down a
problem no certainly not but you know
let's be honest some of these ladies
their company is rather boring so you do
need to spice it up a bit and that's
exactly what i did and i think that they
should be grateful that i came in here
personality plus
who's the most boring erica well the
list is long but it certainly does not
include me
a commentary i saw after the trailer
drop is boring don't even try me we've
been for a long time you can answer that
question yourself i just wanted to hear
it from your mouth i can read your mind
but i know you know what i'm saying i
know what you're saying a commentary i
saw after the trailer dropped is erica
is leaning into full super villain this
season if we're gonna talk about erica's
behavior
are we gonna talk about everybody in
this group how do you feel about that
reading of what oh my god can i tell you
something it's not full super villain
i'm leading into myself i'm leaning into
full protecting erica mode full taking
care of erica who else is going to do
this if i don't and if that ruffles a
few feathers if that looks unladylike if
that offends your you know i don't know
manners then so be it no one's living
this life but me no one is coming to
help me but me
so if i have to roll up my sleeves and
get a little dirty you can trust and
believe i'm going to do that
there is also a lot of talk about you
getting back out there getting back in
the dating scene oh god having sex who
are these flowers from there's a secret
admirer really yes have we had any dates
no i've had some sex though
uh-huh oh good how much are we gonna see
you venture into the dating pool this
season well i'm not dating anyone so
the most that i say is that i'm having
some good contact and that's nice and it
is it's important and i you know i'm
thankful for that
thankful i struggle you know sex is a
good stress reliever
i think some of the women on herod have
more
oh god this is nicer this interview is
going to get you and me in trouble erica
um
what are you talking about this is a
great interview we're both being honest
there is some speculation by sutton that
the men
you're choosing to spend time with
maybe there's a seeking arrangements
kind of energy there what do you what's
your response to that speculation well
if that were true i'd be in a much
bigger house [ __ ] okay i'd have a lot
i'd have a new car some new jewels and a
better wardrobe than i already have but
it's pretty kick-ass so she is wrong
but if i wanted to do that we would all
know in about 2.5 seconds because i
would bag the biggest one there is out
there
oh we see you get into it
today okay if you wanted to she really
books diamond claws are out um
that's a good i i'm stealing that
diamond claws take it um we see you get
into it with a few people in the trailer
probably most famously at this point
garcelle is that to make erica look bad
or is that out of general i don't have
to make you look bad you can do that on
your own
why does it get to this place where we
see that kind of tension
you know i think that garcelle wants
something for me that she's not going to
get
and that is this sort of she has
this perspective about the way i should
behaving
and be behaving and what i should be
doing in regards to my legal situation
and that's just not
you know
i can't do what others want me to do i
have to do what is right for me
safe to say those issues are still
present today may 2022 with carcel
well i think they're
worse okay i mean we all saw the book in
the trash
around the internet first hold on a
second she unfollowed me
and then she put up the post about
making you know how else you can make
yourself look bad and so she swung twice
and there we go
can you solve the mystery was it
actually your copy of the book in your
trash can or was it rinna's copy of the
book in rena's trash or deny either
okay i'm gonna say it was renaissance
um there's also this discussion around
kathy hilton for a year and a half i've
been thinking okay so that's why you
want kathy to be called out yes it is
actually
what leads us to that no hold on it's
not the heat it's behavior if we're
going to talk about erica's behavior
we're going to talk about everyone
else's behavior ad nauseam okay because
that's what has happened here and so
everyone knows no one gets a free pass
and that includes kathy hilton so you
know you sign up you're going to get it
so you just wanted equal
playing field playing field okay yeah i
just wanted an equal playing field
especially when the things that are
happening
uh with kathy happened in public place
and we the members of the cast
were not the only people that witnessed
this
so it's not like you know
that didn't happen
is this all about an alleged slur
i'm not going to say anything about that
okay
why wouldn't she come into the
all right why couldn't she come into the
ski store in aspen
the door is locked should we unlock it
no don't unlock don't unlock
it why did we have to lock her out
because we did
we were in the middle of a conversation
okay with seemingly your new bff diana
love diana oh you're gonna really like
her you talk about someone that gives no
f's that's on an unlike a mega level
well i mean she came in and just
pronounced herself to be the villain so
i think you're a soulless person
you need a new villain here i am well i
think that you know you'll see something
between and diana that hurt diana's
feelings very much and i think that
that's what you're seeing is the
reaction to that because diana's
feelings were very hard and i understand
why
looking ahead to everything is there
anything to look forward for you is it
like launching the haircare line is that
the bright spot in this season well the
um extension line pretty messed hair is
definitely a bright spot and definitely
a great you know business for me and
something that i am proud of and you
know i'm back in the studio i'm back
creating which is super important to me
thanks for the diamond claws don't get
mad if i use it and um
it's good to be creative that's really
bryce where my heart and soul lies and
to get away from some of this pressure
that you know of everything that's been
said would be really nice
on the flip side is there anything that
you are bracing for impact for any
apologies you want to make out the gate
just so that it's settled ahead of time
i apologize to a couple of people um on
the cast and they are heartfelt
apologies whether they are received i
don't know um
but yeah i mean look no one is perfect
and it is when we try to portray
ourselves as perfect that we get in
trouble
so
um and i i
you know apologized for what was
probably not right
do you think you have more apologies to
make by season's end or are you done
apologizing uh i don't i don't think so
i yeah
no i'm pretty good
you